the Justice Department has filed its
first enforcement action against alleged
coronavirus fraud it obtained a
temporary restraining order yesterday
against the website coronavirus medical
kit dot-com prosecutors say the site
claimed to offer consumers access to
vaccine kits from the World Health
Organization it sounds official there
are currently no vaccines to treat this
disease our consumer investigative
correspondent that's Anner Warner Jones
joins us from her home in Berkeley
California so Anna what exactly did this
website claim to offer
so basically gale this website was
claiming to offer vaccine kits from the
World Health Organization they said if
you added water it would work you pay
for ninety five and shipping for this
kit of course we know that there are no
vaccine kits available the only people
doing the tests are state and local labs
and yet there are scammers out there who
are trying to convince people hey
there's something that you can order you
can use it at home and if you do happen
to see one of these kinds of things you
can contact your state attorney
general's office gale but no these are
these are not vaccine kits and there are
none of it it's such a crappy thing to
do to anybody are there any approved
at-home testing kits anywhere that are
legit no there aren't and I'm really
glad you asked that gale I think it's
really important to make clear to people
there are no at-home testing kits the
FDA has not authorized any home testing
kits at all for use so if you see
something that says hey you can test
yourself at home
it's not a real deal here is the
government seeing a lot of these scams
Anna so I found something really
interesting over the weekend so the
Customs and Border Protection has been
tweeting out photos of items that it has
seized one of them is sort of like a box
of little vials they show these pictures
on on Twitter of things that people are
saying are either at home treatments or
they are or they are say one of them
treatment is a treatment kit the acting
commissioner said on Twitter that police
in the UK arrested a man for selling
those kits
and then the other ones are counterfeit
test kits that came through Los Angeles
Airport they were labeled as purified
water files so these are the kinds of
things that people who are you might
call them creative or just call them
scammers frankly are saying hey I can
make a quick buck off of this sell
something to people and one of these
things actually the CBP said had some
what might be dangerous ingredients to
it so there's some there are some
dangers there to you know what are
people listening to when it comes to
robo calls well you know the Robo
callers have jumped into this I'm sure
you're not surprised to hear this they
are saying hey we can clean your home
air ducts your air filters for
coronavirus we also are going to help
you with your student loan payments
you've heard that one before and even
the social security scammers are jumping
in and saying hey there's going to be
something with the corona virus and your
social security number so be careful
about these calls if you get one of
these calls just hang up careful
scammers are gonna scam and thank you
very much